[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link on this week's show we have
Freddie Wong joining us we had a good
conversation with Freddie you were going
to enjoy we talked about what it's like
growing up as a first-generation
chinese-american how he made money off
of a feature-length film that he made
while he was still in high school and
how he became a world champion Guitar
Hero player
for realz you can end more stuff I mean
those are just some of the things that
champion the best in the world at one
time yeah I mean I've never played the
game at all
you've heard of here folks it's it's
called an air biscuit there's plenty of
biscuits to be build out into your ears
today but you were telling me how you've
used to women's restrooms today yeah
they did incidentally it has just worked
out that I first of all I don't use I
don't make a habit of walking into
women's restrooms or using them in
general but it was I think it's illegal
by the way you know what that was what I
was wondering cuz that when I was in the
first one I was thinking is this can I
be arrested for this but what for what
indecent exposure is I mean if it is was
there a woman in there no no it was a
single it was a single person single use
we were at the the car passed the coffee
shop that we were at this morning and I
needed to take a leak just sorry to say
it's got to be blunt with Eunice you
don't need to be blunt that's what I
need but I needed to go to bathroom and
well I'm I think there's a difference if
I had to have it to do the full thing I
don't know if I would have gone in the
women's restroom but so I go to the
men's restroom it's locked and I'm like
listen we need to leave I need to go and
I look and I can tell that there's no
but women's restroom has like a little
crack in the door and I just like look
around real quick and boom I'm in there
and I'll lock it behind me do my deed
and then I and then I leave and I'm
thankful at the time when I walk out
that there's that there's not a woman
standing there that's what it comes down
to doesn't it the I've used that same
women's restroom by the way because
there's a good one because you never
there's been guys who just stay in there
a long time some of them may be homeless
I don't know they may be doing the whole
shower thing it happens in LA the
birdbath
but it's the coin in is easy it's the
coming out that gets dicey you can't
make eye contact with
fishin gonna be waiting is there gonna
be a female there waiting but yeah I do
want to say that yes and then when we
ate it that yes a woman was waiting no
no no woman was waiting but yes it
happened two times a day now the first
time I was in there I was thinking
legitimately is this like against the
law are you getting some restaurant code
or something
it probably not it's suggested this is
the men's and this is the women's I
don't know I yeah if anybody out there
does have an informed legal opinion
about whether it's illegal to go into
the wrong restroom please tweet us at
rhett and Link and let us know and we'll
see that now let me ask you a question
about this did you sit down you just
said you had to do number one I'm not a
woman now I know that but did you feel
like you should do as the women do
because that's the restroom you were in
no I just took special pains to not
splash a lot and I and I made sure the
seat the seat was splashed a lot what
are you doing throwing stones in there
sir splash a lot is my rap man yes sir
so but I you know okay so you know III
was very first of all I noticed and
that's what I wanted to get to was I
noticed that it was a clean and be
smelled good I was like it's a weird
that it smells good in here and then
we're at the Indian restaurant and I
needed to do the same thing this is
lunchtime right well I had to pee
multiple times in it five hours later
and I got to find another woman's
restroom I'm waiting outside of the
men's restroom at this Indian restaurant
and the guy who works there the waiter
is like uh-uh he says go ahead use that
one
there's no ladies here and I was like
okay and so I Walters do women's
restroom again and again it just hit me
like a wall when I walked in it smells
good in here and then it hit me as I
began to think deeper on this that in
general women smell better than men of
course they do all the time you know now
that we're married to women we're
basically in charge of the way our house
looks and smells the house smells good
all the time but I mean that's not their
jobs they have other jobs they but
they're not just I'm saying in in the
particular in our household that is what
the the the girls NR in our
lives they've taken that upon themselves
because they know that we're not gonna
do a good developer pinions about these
yes and I'm just like if you if you want
the bed to look like a princess bed from
like a Barbie house then you go for it
you know I'll sleep in it it'll be great
but the house it looks dark when my eyes
are closed the house smells good and
women smell good in general and I know
that they typically will wear you know
some perfumes and these kinds of things
but there's dudes who wear a cologne but
you can still smell it there's a guy
underneath that cologne you know what I
mean what is it it's just a futile
covering that's what cologne should say
on it because men use its its pheromones
oh really oh really it's pheromones and
that's what makes me feel better about
it
it sends a signal that to to women and
now just to my wife only send it to her
oh you're saying I am masculine and I I
stink because I do things that I conquer
things like earth and sod and I'm going
women's restroom and when women aren't
looking I haven't seen dirt under your
fingernails in 12 years but there's
still some there and it smells funny
I can bet you that I I yeah it's some
sort of hormonal thing it's not that we
smell badass is that we don't smell good
let's just put it that was just guys in
a room over time he gets bad but girls
in room over time it doesn't get are you
saying that by speaking of the smell of
women's restrooms that women's poop
doesn't stink is that what you're
getting at
cleaning Western I'm beginning to
develop a sincere inquiry in Korea can
say that worked
I live with I am in wiring into whether
or not women's food stinks you live with
a woman I do not go in and when she's
pooping because if it doesn't this
really where this conversation is gone
are we doing this again I are we having
it's just so pathetic man did we do this
in like in one of the first episodes was
there like bathroom humor there always
is I wouldn't call this bathroom humor I
would just call that bathroom talk I'd
call it pathetic I'm sorry for I know
there
those of you out there who have an
aversion about sensation every if you're
above it if you're above it you must be
some sort of alien that's all I gotta
say I live with two women and and there
are times when they rival anything I've
ever put out okay let's get into this
conversation that we have with Freddie
and in case you don't happen to know it
already guy is a YouTube power he's got
over 6.5 million subscribers on his
YouTube channel that he shares with his
friend Brandon that's the Freddie W
channel you didn't want to say brain his
last name I don't know how to say like I
mean he's got a lot of RAM and lat shut
a lot of valves it has 80s C and H
altogether so if you say that
phonetically it's lat there's no way
that's how you're supposed to say it
so latch let's just call him Brandon
they just completed the second season of
the narrative series video game high
school you've probably heard of it it's
got you know bazillions of views and
it's it's narrative so it's it's
breaking some ground on the YouTube
space it is in my opinion and we broke
some Brown today with mr. Freddie Wong
here it is our conversation with him so
you found this place I mean it could be
kind of shady but we turned on the
yellow light oh yeah I'm a yellow light
was on I was like okay one bit yeah I
found it okay it's a mysterious location
it's purposeful it's almost it's almost
as I would say even like nice Pete's all
is he still in that recording studio
it's a house yeah it was random like huh
you hmm okay this is nice that's what
you're going with I mean is up but
that's also like similar stealth mode
you know they never you never find that
well you don't want to put a sign up
right I mean no but it looks like a
freaking house he's like a house we did
make the mistake although one time of
putting up a sign because we had some we
had some people coming for interviews
mm-hmm and at this location yeah yeah
and so we put up a little sign on the
front because there's no indicator that
we're here and it was like rhett and
Link studios we came up with a new so
temporary name
rincon rincon lat and we put it up for
about 30 minutes and in that 30 minute
window a family a dad and two kids came
knocking no way man and did you give him
the job or yeah we we gave the kid we
charged them for photos you know if I
thing is and I'll tell you what the
complete opposite of that mentality is
is the this madman rob dyrdek rob dyrdek
has the fantasy factory very close to
where we were downtown and it's like
well I wonder where it is cuz you know
we're doing a shoot with them and we we
know it has to be around here has to be
we've seen these you know the videos
like it's just like this area has to be
right and then we're like where is that
we got Google Maps and there's one
street in the entirety of that area next
to us that's completely not Google
mapped out like that's got to be it
like who why would this one Street not
be mapped out when every other Street is
we go there sure enough it is but he has
his name on the side of the buildings
dyrdek enterprises so he went through
the trouble Blackey now Google Maps but
yeah last name and what's crazy as we go
in and it's like every time we were
doing it it could tech scout or just you
know check the space out or talk to him
every time we came out without fail
three or four people holding signs being
like Rob Rob it's Robin there hey hey
hey yeah you know if I'm mr. dyrdek goes
in there and everybody was pitching him
business ideas like they had like I got
this crazy
this dude was there with like this
bizarre by clicking the track
contraption he's like I got this
unicycle bike man and I think Rob would
just dig it dude
and it's like oh he's pitching me you
yeah and what's crazy is because I think
it's because there's a couple of shows
it's like he's all about like yo man
take the crazy ideas that you have and
turn it into you know like that's like a
unicycle gotta come in no he's just as
like those people out there man I don't
even send him my way crazy no telling to
sit outside our door on the unicycle and
the unicycle you mean the unicycle guy I
thought you met Rob no I was like it was
a double unicycle thing that's called a
bicycle yeah it was
well mother was was both but here's what
was there's both wheel sets or
independent so you could like turn them
and do like the tightest radius two
turns
you could there's two wheels right next
to each other no no two wheels in the
bicycle formation but both had
independent torque ability torsional
ability so it'd be I could bicycle but
both if the handlebar side was on if the
handlebars work on both sides hmm so you
could do like crazy it's like a hook and
ladder firetruck it steers from both
ends
yeah right I have a story about that by
the way one of the funniest stories that
we've ever had okay are we going yeah
yeah this is it
oh this is it yeah times good times do
you have a story about a hook and ladder
five shot so we have been so you know
okay we'll get look at you know here's
what we'll do okay we will get to this
story just a bit teaser in order to
properly contextualize a story we need
go back yeah well we were gonna ask you
to go back all the way to do you guys
have an intro is this is it we're on
yeah we do the intro after you leave
don't try to produce our podcast we've
got this but let's go all the way back
okay
to baby Freddie okay so I uh Seattle I
was born Seattle okay I was born in a
neighborhood called Normandy Park and
Normandy Park is notable for two things
as far as I'm concerned retirement homes
and churches and that's it and that's
all that we had there and that's what
sort of had we lived in a cul-de-sac and
so who did you grow up with a little
cul-de-sac I grew up with my brother my
younger brother Jimmy who was like a
year and a half younger than me and a
small smorgasbord of neighborhood kids
and we would you need to be behind seek
they be street hockey less street hockey
cuz it's cold sack right we need the
cul-de-sac for street hockey you can
have an eraser sack and you play street
hockey nope you missed out too dangerous
no he lives on one now right now is
their street hockey going on no run but
you could introduce you could introduce
it man you could be like darn it yeah
you could be the cool dude on this end
yeah hey kids my PVC pipe what is the
puck for street hockey it's a it's a
it's a puck that has three spherical
balls in it to elevate it a little bit
and give it free of this and less of
relapse
roll off the ground yeah exactly or in a
pinch tennis ball yep
so street hockey was the thing on our
street and I was the goalie although as
the goalie which looking back now
because all the other kids were playing
with her older than me like three or
four years older than me
looking back now I was the one that's
getting the bum deal at the time it
seemed like a cool thing
oh yeah it was like yeah they need this
and he's a goalie man like they did I'm
the one stopping the puck in there and
then I realized oh they needed someone
you were the target how was the target
yeah exactly but I will say it was a
hell of a goalie street hockey goalie
that's good I'm not gonna not gonna step
back from that I was pretty good so okay
anyway you need this you need the
cul-de-sac for street hockey as
otherwise too much too many through too
much through traffic is ridiculous
you guys stop the game every 30 seconds
playing a game you know so that was the
thing we even run around summertime
growing up you know school's just around
that area if you have both your parents
growing up had both my folks my dad and
my mom dad a anesthesiologist so a sleep
doctor and he worked at the hospital
which was like five minutes from my
house was really close it was fine soaps
so basically he was really good at
counting backwards yeah and never did it
and I mean it had to be frustrating
being an anesthesia they never get down
to one you know start with 10 right yeah
yeah you start with 10 and so I was like
I bet you there's a pool going on and
then in the operating room
well medicine lingo there I can take a
mid nine like that doctors a full-on
nine and a half doctor back from him
yeah there's there's the most boring
show most boring medical show ever about
anesthesiologists a bunch of guys
sitting there looking at heart monitors
and being like think would you adjust
the dosage for this guy let's kick it up
a little bit all right yeah he's a hefty
guy yeah but that's it let's bite his
finger see what happens you know
and the funny thing about so the
fighting about growing up so my folks
are both from China originally so they
emigrated here in the they are Chinese
they are full Chinese yes so I'm first I
don't know what is a my first generation
their 0th generation I'm first
generation Chinese technically yeah and
when they went to Seattle is interesting
for people who know sorce al geography
they were looking at places to get a
house
and to settle down and they looked at
two places one is Normandy Park by
virtue of the fact that nobody has ever
heard of Normandy Park even in Seattle
you know that they did pick the wrong
choice because the other place which was
like really cheap and like maybe we
should go here was this place called
Mercer Island and Mercer Island is in
the middle of Lake Washington and in the
time since I think the property values
on bursar al has probably like
quadrupled quintupled because it's like
literally every rich Microsoft exactly
was like that's where my house will be
so it's like Bill Gates house Mercer
Island
oh yeah all the crazy rich like people
in Seattle all the tech guys came they
all came and they just like bought up
all of Mercer Island the first place to
get cable internet in the United States
Mercer Island and cable Internet by the
way when they showed up this has been
jumping all over the place which is fine
but when I first showed up my friend
Barry lived on Mercer Island and he had
cable internet he came in the school one
day he was like guys here is this this
is like probably 7th grade 6th grade for
me so what do you mean when you first
showed up when he capable Internet you
mean oh it first showed up Mary got it
Barry got it first you've been there
I've been there we were here dialing up
56k DSL DSL was huge you kidding 35
kilobytes down are you kidding are you
kidding he comes in he's like fluff hey
man won't cut your internet DSL man 35
kilobytes down I can get any real player
stream I want and he goes dude I got
this Internet it goes through your TV
and it's 500 kilobytes out I'm like shut
up Barry you liar you liar Barret and
then what then the next week when my
friends was like dude that was that
Barry's house he's not lying man Barry
was great and then he was also the guy
who first saw the matrix when it came
out and he was like guys guys there's
this movie you got to see it's about
it's rated R so you got to tell your
parents to let you in but it's like
about bees it's a second world and
there's like telephone lines what shut
up Barry this sounds like the dumbest
movie ever is no I'm not kidding
then the next week we all go work that
was amazing how dare he was an advanced
kid but in your mind's eye futurist
he was like every single week he would
have said he was like Benny and I think
every school had this but he was the kid
that was like laser
five bucks each kid there's a guy we had
been Greenwood growing up he was the guy
who you're like okay this is before the
internet for us this is before the
Internet this is like when you wanted to
learn something you had to looking
encyclopedia or the library and he knew
everything I'm like how do you know all
this stuff yeah there's always a berry
there's always a bin and you gotta have
him as a friend you have to oh he was
and he was the guy that uh yeah he knew
his uh dudes acoustic guitar it's where
it's at boom like he was like yo get it
the ladies Dave Matthews mixtape check
it you know it's like whoa damn then was
the thing Greenwood was the type of guy
who would go over to his house and he
would have this grand scheme let's hike
out miles behind my back yard and let's
dam up the creek back there to create a
fishing pond it's gonna take a few days
but we can do it so we would dam up the
creek and then he would go and catch
fish from a pond and we would bring them
and we would put them into the creeks
every night for a couple of days we
would have a fishing pond until the dam
broke
he always smoked these things called big
Jordan George because this weed that we
found out in the woods that had a big it
was just a hollow shaft and he was like
ideally suited for this activity we
should smoke these and they would put
anything in the show you just light it
you know of course we should this is six
sixth grade right and it was pretty
weird we had a guy like that too we so
so I grew up so him went to high school
I went to you know great school whatever
you know just hung around high school I
went to this super duper preppy ass rich
kid High School which was all the way on
the other side of where Seattle awesome
but weren't you one of those - it's not
compared to some of my classmates and so
what were they you know I have and tell
me if I'm wrong about this shirt what
the impression that I've gotten from
first-generation Asian Americans is yes
is that there are these especially your
dad being anesthesiologist there are
these excellent pressure oh yeah yeah no
absolutely did that exist in your
household so here's is really here's
what I think it's kind of interesting
and my brother and I have a have amongst
my peers of sort of unique experience
growing up
which is we had that at first and then
over time our parents kind of rapidly
figured out that that's not the way to
do it so when I was like was it like
starting so what started like I did
piano lessons I'm wicked at classical
piano I will I'm that Asian kid who will
be like yo hide in Beethoven sonatas
sitting there 12 years old I have no
anxiety when I get on stage or if I'm
from a group of people and I think that
was completely pounded out of me from
being like all right dude it's time to
play piano
you better you've been practicing for
hours a day on this this this Prelude
and Fugue you better nail it there's
three judges here who are Bach experts
you know and it's like everyone's
listening they'll screw this up through
this stuff like that kind of performance
anxiety so to speak from an early age
anything every Asian kind of gets a
little bit of that so so we the piano
lessons and you know it was and and I
think they kind of slowly they figured
it out they're like you know what
because that's our play I was like mom I
don't like you know I was in high school
so I don't want to play piano anymore
like I don't want to keep practicing
what am I gonna be am I gonna be a
professional piano player like what
what's the end goal here right and she
said no you're not gonna be a
professional piano player you're not
good enough number one and then number
two which is like well we wanted to
instill an appreciation of music and and
she's like one day you're gonna thank me
for that
and she's right you know like having
being able to understand music from from
that level it's one of those things
where it's like dang I here's what it is
looking back on it now as a 20 or 28
year old adult quote a male it's you
don't remember sitting at in front of
the piano for two hours a day and summer
and being like I want to play video
games you don't remember that at all
it's just like a wisp of memory and
you're in the back your head what you do
remember is the end result of that and
that is like wow I know I can appreciate
music in a different way and I can pick
up an instrument really quickly now and
I understand this and I understand all
these sort of things from music I forgot
all the crap leading up to it
but right now I'm in this island of
memory where I don't remember that but I
have all the advantages from it it's
similar also to I think people who'd
like their parents put them through like
gymnastics or dance because it's like I
have a friend of mine who he be his
periscope through like three years of
gymnastics and he's like this is
emasculating and it's just horrible but
la dude's ripped now you don't need to
do crap you're just like hey I just want
to lose some weight
ripped instantly it's like dang that's
like gymnastic that's perfect
this is becoming borderline motivational
okay so so that was kind of the internal
pressure room but only led up somewhat
of an externally gross not really you
know because it was you know I was I was
in a area that was it was not a lot of
it wasn't okay to use the asian term it
wasn't a fabi area right so Fabi is
fresh off the boat and so there are
areas that are like is very fabi
quote-unquote you know it's like oh
these guys it's very insular community
wise you sort of retain a lot of this
sort of cultural aspects from you didn't
really see that there's only I can think
of maybe a couple neighborhoods in
Seattle it's more prevalent down
Southern California actually you know
when you talk about like a hombro or
places like that was like that this a
little more insular so it wasn't like
that so we come we're just very much
Americanized very quickly did you have a
did you have a I want to be a so-and-so
when I grow up its back in high school
or earlier well early on the thing that
I was I was convinced I was going
towards was computer programming because
I was like a total computer nerd and my
dad's a computer nerd too and he would
we got like we first computers like the
at the Apple to see on a five inch 5 and
a half inch floppy disk and I was like
messing around on the basic on the to
see and using the dual floppy disk
drives and stuff and I remember all that
stuff and and that was kind of like the
directions like I'm I think it's gotta
be it's gotta be videos ever start up
it's gotta be programming it's got a
computer stuff you know that's kind of
direction that my inclinations were
going towards and even in high school
even high school yeah cuz that's where
you weren't you were kind of wall so so
so I went to a high school with a really
interesting group of people and it was a
very frou-frou as I said sort of college
preppy high schools called lakeside and
lakeside known for
our most specifically known for Bill
Gates was the guy who went there and
Lakeside's where Bill Gates met Paul
Allen and they started the little
computer club that started like
literally the seed of Microsoft is there
and then I like to point out Adam West
went to uh went to Lakeside and Vanna
White so to sort of mavens of Industry
Vanna White
yeah we're good Vanna White is from
Myrtle Beach yes Linna I don't know this
is the maybe she didn't this is
something that is has been in my head
everybody said as I famous alum I'm not
sure we're not calling you I mean you
know I mean you could be right you go to
Myrtle Beach a trip after Seattle or
high schools in America try to claim
Vanna White everywhere by the way can we
just talk for a second about how her job
has been down she does even turned those
letters screen of enabled things like
come on it I don't even think it's like
when I am pedestrian to something at the
computer here I don't touch the screen
because I don't like to get my
fingerprints on it
I think they've even told her we want
you to look like you're touching the
letter so it's all tonight Foley yeah
there's actually touch them there's a
guy on a computer he's covering for her
to get close to it and then he's hitting
a button
oh my she doesn't even have to be there
at all that's a pretty heavy that's
pretty heavy I gotta say if you really
think about that in terms of like
looking back at your life it's like now
I just I don't even actuate these
buttons a man does that from behind the
scenes but we but we love you for it
Vanna she's listening she's a big fan we
appreciate all that you do come on
Freddie work with us here sorry no this
the poster behind the door on the way
and okay I just it's signed I see that
now so excuse me sorry about that so the
lakeside lakeside Lakeview lakeside
lakeside yeah and it's uh it so it has
this a reputation and it was like it was
like it was a kind of weird hardcore
school and came to academics and and all
that stuff is very very notoriously
difficult to get into the kids all went
through and there had a reputation I had
the fortunate sort of thing of my class
was a so class size about 100 1112
people my class was all really
interesting people and it was like the
kind of thing where I think like even
the teachers like made a note of that I
remember when we were graduating and
even this
back now like your class was weird
because I I think pretty much everybody
in that class was just friends with each
other like there was no cliques there
was no like there were groups of people
hung out but it wasn't just like oh yeah
I don't like that guys like no she's
like yeah he's cool everyone was kind
just cool with each other we just kind
of did our thing so it was at Lakeside I
started off doing computer stuff I've
actually good story about that I was
working in making websites internally at
the lakeside school and I made one for
the Parents Association ok Parents
Association kinda like the PTA right and
they needed an update on their website
and so I'm gonna do that
so February 14th rolls around better
this will give you an idea of where I
was socially before the movie thing
happens while talking about them and
we'll get to that in a second so
Valentine's Day Valentine's it working
on the high school website yeah people
for the Parents Association its we all
have y'all cubby holes at this at the
school low mailbox and there's there's a
one that they call them candy grams aka
you could purchase through some student
organization couple bucks get a little
Valentine thing put deliver to a person
of your choosing yeah in the whole I had
one that year I was like oh my gosh who
is this you received one I received one
I saw it from across the hallway this
little thing sticking out I was wrong
last letter to the name bottom right
corner there it is Mike oh my goodness
previous years it seemed it was
according to precedent that this would
be this is a unprecedented event in
every definition of that work so I go to
my hole right over that I do not dear
Freddie thanks for helping on the
website the parents from the parents
from everyone yeah that's a good twist
it is and then and so so end of
sophomore year and the freshman year the
iMac came out and the iMac was a big
thing about the iMac remember was it
could take mini DV and edit mini DV and
iMovie so in this little like different
colors it was different colors had the
blue one in this little class thing and
this little class thing that we
had it was like you know five or six
people it was just a bunch of students
just doing helping out with the IT side
of the school so what the class was so
that's how I was doing the Parents
Association website so the iMac came out
and we had a camera and my friend Reid
and I were like well let's just kind of
mess around with this camera and just
shoot something stupid look who's come
for like a class assignment and this was
a time and I think this is still the
case but if you do a video for a class
assignment welcome to instant a
territory lay oh yeah yes like like the
teachers are so blown away by the fact
that you have combined image and sound
in a moving form right like it's a just
you only have the feeling to think about
it they know it's on tape they just
literally put an A on the tape they have
no context to judge it right it's
impossible to give anything less than an
a because just the sheer effort there
anyway so that's the trick still works I
think to this day but we did it was like
it was a class product for a Chinese
class it was like we shot this
ridiculous little action piece movie
like I'm sneaking into a thing everybody
wanted you to be in their group for that
one I guess no no this is this is
actually just on our own almost it
wasn't actually it was kind of thing
we're just I don't even remember the
details but we're just messing around
you know and so we shot this little
thing I'm you know all over the school
and it's got like it's like me sneaking
arounds got like the freaking Metal Gear
Solid music and stuff like again nerd
territory ladies and gentleman and we
decided to do just like a little hey we
got this done five minutes long we added
together iMovie let's let's do a little
thing let's put it out and and do a
little screening in the library the
library had a lot aureum we did the
other year I'm like whoa a lot of people
show up for this I think we packed the
place at 250 kids just show up to watch
it and people were like losing it that
was really funny and sometimes like so
my friend reading they're like let's do
a feature-length movie if he was a
junior I was a sophomore let's do it
let's do a feature-length movie and
we'll do it kind of off this original
little thing we called it the boo Hal
movie which was in Chinese visitors for
a Chinese class project it means the not
good movie and what are you shooting on
to this at this point it is shooting on
a what is it it's like it's a mini DV or
a high oh no it's a digital 8'o digital
a fattie camera with wide angle adaptor
bought from eBay for
$35 which is a princely sum at the time
ready to drop on something like that and
so we're like okay let's let's do it so
that was like I shifted from doing the
wanting to be a computer programmer to
movies is really interesting to me and
like movies is actually something that I
really enjoyed doing during that year
like I really enjoyed that process that
trying to get people together to do
something ridiculous in front of a
camera and then trying to just get all
these pieces together and putting it out
and seeing people react to it so for the
rest of my high school we were doing
just you know little short videos and
stuff some of which by the way exist on
our channel to this day it's just like
little high school things like I did one
where one night we sleep over a friend's
house and we're like hey it was 3:00 I'm
like hey let's let's put cardboard all
over your Volvo like sedan and make it
look like a racing car so we put like
side skirts like I think like rice
rocket so like front hood scoop spoiler
we went to his laser jet printer and
print out a bunch of fake like logo like
brand names and stuff and like taped
them on like this ridiculous let's make
a video out of it and we did we made
like a quick video we're just driving
around at night we got pulled over by
the cops and and and the cop was like he
came up and he was like well I was gonna
write you a ticket because your side
skirts need to be higher than the rim of
your wheels but I mean it's cardboard
what do you guys so can I ask you what
you're doing at 3:00 in the morning
driving this thing around and my buddy
smooth-talker was like well you know
we've doing this for a school project
and we figured if we drove it around
during the day it would be a little more
distracting and the guy was just like
all right good ride that school project
thing a long ways until you get great
here oh yeah you can oh that guy I still
have my student ID in my car are you
kidding I go the movie theorum like um I
got the student discount graduate
student it's cuz as far as I'm concerned
that's like that's like come on man like
you gotta get your tuition back somehow
like one three dollar discount at a time
one half one small popcorn with every a
small drink purchase at a time we're
getting that student discount pack okay
so you're in high school you make this
discovery that you you
you like filmmaking yeah and then you
begin to put together a the idea that
maybe this is something bigger than a
hobby yeah absolutely and at the time
was like doing a little short videos and
stuff and you know the funny thing is I
always think that what I think about a
lot is the idea of timing you know and
and I was reading you know like a
Gladwell even talks about this you know
where he wears like Bill Gates and Paul
Allen and Steve Jobs and and and Bill
Pope and like all these like computer
pioneers they're all like within two
years of each other in terms of age
because when the technology hit they
were the right age to take advantage of
it to not be too entrenched in a career
otherwise and not be too young to be
late to the party like they're just the
right age and I think about that a lot
with like YouTube because what we were
doing that you're messing around you
know doing these little assembly videos
like I would I would do little videos
for like the soccer team or the rowing
team or something to be a little fun
like literally what I end up doing which
is like short kind of visual effects II
two-minute videos we play in an assembly
and that was the only Avenue we had we
put that in assembly that'd be it and I
think about now where it's like you have
YouTube and it's like these kit you see
kids who are like rock stars in their
schools like these guys play video games
and they got call duty commentator and
then I'm buying the Mercedes with this
and that make more money than my parents
and here's me with girls it's like what
what no what that's not come on come on
right so I think about that I'm like and
I think about now sort of my time you
know in timing in terms of where I am
right now I was like what is it feels
very much like this is the just right in
terms of timing you know just the right
time for we're at where there was video
and there was a thing and I got familiar
with it and it was it was the idea of it
was there and if YouTube was around in
high school you know maybe that was even
would have been a better sort of time
for us but feels like it may be a little
late to it but I was kind of doing
something similar in high school and I
didn't even realize it and until later
until looking back now it's just doing
that I was doing a lot of what a lot of
these high school kids got into and have
gone into YouTube from back in high
school but I was there was nothing to
put it there's nowhere to put hell
outlet no outlet for it
parents respond to that and so this is
this is what I think I have to give a
lock rats my parents were there like
cool if you want to do this go for it
that was it there's no you know and I
think it was the kind of thing where
like my dad reads a lot of Businessweek
and and Wall Street Journal he does a
lot of thinking having come from
Communist China to adopt a new home here
in the US he thinks a lot about like
where is the u.s. going and what is this
place that I'm in and how you know and
then obviously he has he's very strong
her political beliefs but his but his
thing has always been look America is
not theirs what do we have that we're
doing like what car manufactures what
India and China's are gonna do that
physical manufacturer India and China
and programming and he's he I think
recognized kind of [ __ ] recognize at the
end of my high school he was like look I
think you're getting into the right
field because the only thing America is
gonna have is cultural exports that's
the only thing we have our you have the
music industry you have Hollywood that's
it like what else is there that we do
that in some other country is not hungry
or for and can do it cheaper than us and
we'll do it cheaper than us so there's
nothing like that that's it like
Hollywood movies still have that stamp
around the world music still has that
stamp it's as export our chief export is
cultural products so he's like I think
you're actually getting into a field
where cuz he was like if you were doing
in programming he called this like
literally five years before this happens
and you get into programming you're
gonna have a hard time getting a job cuz
look at India look at China all these
kids are growing up and they're gonna be
better programmers gonna do it cheaper
and they're just gonna be willing to and
they're gonna work harder for it than
you because you you're in this
environment where you have someone say
enhance so many things handed to you
instead nice environment compared to
China or India mmm-hmm so that's a
little different than the conversation
that I had with my dad because our our
story is pretty similar in that we work
well and the conversation with your dad
I'll let you tell it but it it was a
hinge point for both of our lives
because for me it was what we we both
talked about going to film school and it
basically came down to what rets dad
thought because I knew that my mom would
just say okay whatever whatever you want
to do but read dad had we had to get
buy-in we were shooting on just to give
you a little this is a little bit of the
indicator of the difference in our
future we were shooting on a VHS si
oh yeah so and just for just for
reference vhs-c
hi eight digital eight that's sort of
that was the timeline right so we were
shooting on that we had begun to shoot a
feature-length film in high school
gutless wonders which we've read the
script on good mythical morning late
last season but so we had these
aspirations I'm sure that what we were
creating was not as impressive as what
you were creating at the time but it was
difficult you had to edit on to VCR no
I'm saying again that's timing right
like right if it wasn't for that because
I remember I remember like early on my
dad got like this thing called The
Matrix 1000 I'd lose the matrix 1000
which was the first Mac card that could
do 640 by 360 or six-pointed by 480 DV
not DV sorry high 8 capture off of
s-video there was no digital stuff not
but when I told my dad I was like link
and I have decided that we want to go to
film school yeah and he was like well
that's great I'm not gonna pay for it he
says but if you want if you want to do
something the more you'll actually get a
job then at Danelle I'll pay for it so
that's why we both have engineering
degrees you're good you're good at math
yeah that's what our counselor in high
school said and I do think what you see
what you're saying with timings plays
such a huge role in it because by the
time we had we're linking our kind of
slow developers in a lot of ways I think
we kind of discovered late bloomers like
gosh but by the time we got to a place
what we were making could work on in the
YouTube space that we had hair on parts
of my body you didn't even know about
when we were young man well I'm glad I
didn't know yeah that's true I'm glad
you didn't know either so anyway you're
grateful you're grateful took free to
your dad for having that foresight now
yeah for my for both my parents you know
and I think I think that yeah for the
sort of Asian thing if we want to get
sort of racial and kind of pontificate
on that for a little bit it's kind of an
interesting place that we operate in
society you know we are in terms of like
the minorities we're not high up on the
list you know comparatively to like a
history
african-americans are statistically it
just percentage-wise higher part of the
country but there's this sort of weird
thing that we do and the thing that we
do is we keep our heads down and we just
kind of do our and we don't bother other
people and we kind of just do it and
that's kind of like this attitude that I
see a lot in terms of you know it's
doctors lawyers dances like hey just
keep your head down get good grades get
the job you know family just provide for
it and very non-intrusive it's not like
it's only relatively recently you ever
hear about like oh he's an American
protest about something and it's like
and who are this usually you know it's
the Berkeley kids almost always as
Berkeley kids like you know but it's
just like this it's not thing you just
never hear about that sort of side of it
we just sort of kept out of it you know
and I think it's interesting and I think
it has its Reaper cussed in kind of
interesting ways in American society in
terms of what that role is you know we
can go forever on this is a whole
separate pocket but anyway the point is
it's really and to me it's really
interesting because it's because it I
think the family structure encourages
Asians to kind of like stay out of the
spotlight you know and I think for a
number of historical reasons or a lot
reasons that makes sense but I think
that's just sort of the way that it's
it's been you know so so when I said hey
I wanna make movies it's very much like
boom I want you to entertain I want to
do this and you know at the time I had
no idea about you had no idea that this
was how it would end up but it's a very
big difference between doing that and
wanting to just be like hey I can play
piano and I'd like to be a doctor please
you know uh-huh so that was so that was
so what the USC I went to I went to
University Southern California because
supposedly was the better film school
and you know that was that and so that I
went there I met a lot of the people I
work with today there and just a Bin's
we're working on that stuff ever since
from that point and you met that's where
you met Brandon yep met Brandon there
your roommate he and I lived on the same
floor I met Brandon there our floor is
an interesting floor so I'm praying
there I met Brian firenzi there who is
the creator of 5 second films com
it yeah everyone I Matt Arnold who
co-creator of a geek in high school with
me I've got a writer des dolly also a
co-founder or rocketjump with me he and
I were all three of those guys we were
all in the same practical special
effects class like the first thing he
took everyone that was like a practical
VFX class and we were all in that same
class and then only by the way only like
until I clay tur was like oh crap we
were all in that same class even though
we were all like last paired up in
separate groups but we kind near each
other and it was just like um yeah I
guess what you get in film school is you
get a group of people you're forced to
work with and that's nice for some
people who aren't like you know total
social butterflies who don't know how to
necessarily work a room and and and
network around and get a whole bunch of
contacts it's like no it's nice to be
able to be an environment which there
are no stakes because you're supposedly
learning things and you get to mess
around and you have a bunch of people
now upon graduation that you can
collaborate with and you and you
essentially are living proof that you
know that deciding to put your stuff out
there for an audience is that's a
strategy that works it works for you
yeah and so so how did that how did that
transition take place okay so so after
graduation you know the first gig I got
was doing freelance editing at this
horrible horrible startup I have no
problem saying that the boss was crazy
dude was a crazy who's a Yeller and
everyone's kind of scared of him and
they made inspirational short films and
this is a funny way of ironic yeah I
know right and here's their model by the
way and this is insane
not not too far removed from the reality
but here was them he was a model if they
did it was like a fun there's the things
that they were trying they're like
alright this film is free for you to
watch but you send it to a friend they
have to pay a dollar where is it cuz 30
cents they're your friend they're more
likely to pay ya what so I literally
left that after like 30 days forget this
place
you gotta charge your friends to watch
it you crazy yeah oh my gosh and then I
worked at 20 Century Fox in the video
license video game division which is to
say that the crappy video games
efficient cuz licensed games are all
horrible and and so how long were you
there how did that I was there for about
a year and right when the housing crisis
happened was when I quit because I heard
word from Brandon that a couple of his
friends from Minnesota were up in
Vancouver and they had linked up with
this sales agent who was giving them
money to do a feature film for
direct-to-dvd directed TV called dark
island at the time was called infected
but then they had to change it because
there was a book series called infected
and the author threatened to sue them
and it was about basically a creature
feature featuring the smoke monster from
lost more or less that sort of like
that's our thing because they had this
plug-in called fume effects that could
do smoke CG smoke and it was like this
is it man we could do a smoke monster so
they did smoke monster
so they took like I think it was 40,000
to go shoot a feature film up in the up
in Vancouver and they were finished with
and they're coming to LA and they were
looking for a place to stay which was
eventually where where those loft the
lot that you see was where they stayed
and they have stayed sense and they were
looking for people to help out and I was
like alright I want to do movie stuff
anyway this is what I want to do and I'm
not doing it right now doing this video
game thing although I learned quite a
bit from that in terms of just how the
entertainment industry and these
companies work it was okay oh hey guys
what do you want me to do I can do music
I can do sound effects or the sound
design whatever you guys need all sit
down do it so that's how I met them I
remember walking in to this loft and
everyone sitting at computers pounding
away it's cold because there's no
there's no heat here at all and I was
like hey I won't quit my job and I'll
help you guys do this all right you have
a keyboard like yeah all right got a
board yeah keep it firm for MIDI for
making the music and sound design I was
hopped up on my USC sound design classes
I knew how to use Pro Tools and you had
to do sound design and that was it
that's how I looked up with Sam and Eco
quarter digital and we made we sat there
for about like eight months post doing
post through this movie and we'll
everybody will be the first ammendment
yeah it's not that good of a movie was a
good learning experience it was really
interesting new dark island dark
yeah you can torrent it too if you
really want to see it so 2010 rolls
around and I my friend David and I he
was a hey there's this contest to go to
Vancouver you wanna you wanna go join
this and and and let's see if we can
like get on this contest it's for the
for the Olympics for the Winter Olympics
that Samsung's putting on so we do it
and we get picked as one of the teams
again drawing upon my history of doing a
little short crap you internet videos or
in little short videos in high school
it's like okay yeah okay so we get onto
this thing and there I met DeStorm this
one was one of the other guys on it and
I was like he was like I'm a YouTube
partner what's that mean
is it wanna make money doing this and I
was just like what how how many views do
you need how many people do you have
subscribe to you how long does it take
before you get paid how much money can
you make in a month I just drew it I
just went and just info dumps and he's
just like yeah no problem just told me
everything that he knew yes they just
say another day another challenge yeah
it was like it was crazy cuz he was like
10 stories about like just oh yeah this
guy does it like this and the mic all
the crap so I'm calling Brandon from
Vancouver and being like hey I think we
could we should do this YouTube channel
thing man like I met this guy a storm
and he's like he makes a living off of
it and at the time I had the option of
directing a direct-to-dvd movie or doing
something else and I remember I remember
in October so sort of two things happen
October 2009
I got flown out to Finland for Guitar
Hero because if people don't know I was
like really good at guitar hero for a
while and I was like I got flown around
to play guitar hero yeah saying you're
really good and then you got around well
you were the world champion I was for a
bit according to the world series of
video games and now people the Guitar
Hero purists will argue that my
technical ability is insufficient
compared to a couple of other guys which
I will not be mown than that fact
however I don't think anybody was I mean
I made the point of playing it
ridiculously like air guitar style like
you know windmills and chests and
showmanship right because I'm like this
is gotta be entertaining because I'm
getting style points style points so my
style points are off the charts man we
have to go back a little bit here
because I I'm fascinated by this aspect
oh yeah yes so in 2009 yeah yeah yeah
which is a
thousand seven world series of video
games guitar who came out and
Thanksgiving I remember buying it
because I was reading on the forum some
forum like yeah this games really cool I
bought at ps2 and I was like easy easy
as I am and try expert on I just played
through the whole game on expert which
didn't seem weird to me at the time but
apparently it's a hard game that really
unusual again this is weird this is like
so everyone's a how much time you
practice Mike I just cut the piano maybe
and I play a little guitar anyway so I
don't know I just don't really I just
get it I don't mind I don't really
practice that much so do the houses so
mm like six Tests and there's like there
was a 1-up calm contest for a convivial
contest for the Guitar Hero 2 so that
was the original Guitar Hero YYZ while I
said the video on our channel which was
something we did for that contest
Brandon hi and that was me playing
through why was he and just be able to
take this with it and that was that and
then there was like so the world's hears
of a game stars and I've been playing
guitar hero too and it's in it's in
Dallas Texas and I'm in Seattle that
summer and my friends are like you gotta
go to this dude you got it you could win
this I'm like I don't know man like what
do you tell like dude go like it's kind
of expensive my friends is like how much
is it I'll pay you to go we'll pull it
together you pay me back if you win plus
15% but I'll straight-up stake you in
this tournament dude so I'm like alright
I'll do it so I that wasn't interesting
that was a weird dinner conversation
like mom dad this weekend I was thinking
of flying to Dallas to compete in a
videogame competition for bright for
Guitar Hero yeah the one that yep and it
has like could you win this are you any
good at this game I'm like I think I can
win it alright go for it I think I can
win this day the strings came in and in
the score it was much more like I don't
give it like it was so much more like
what we're this weekend okay fine
whatever who's paying for your friends
your friends are paying for you 15% okay
whatever fine so I went down I went in
one of the like I wasn't one of the
tournament rounds I was like one of the
open rounds they picked people from the
open rounds I play the heart crazy on
you and I took out my sandal and like
strum they just went crazy with it and
everyone's like okay
I went crazy on it man and and then I
won that tournament that weekend so you
were a walk-on I was a walk-on man came
won that tournament playing in Dallas
you remember it was a less talk more
rock the fries pop song of course yeah
and so this is Dallas this is the World
Series video games in Dallas and I could
I I used that aspect I was a world
champion because they called it the
world series of the games and there
wasn't really a main that guitar whoo
things going on at the time and that was
it now so but then the world students
before they got to LA we had this plan
out for LA that I'm so bummed never
happened because the one the tour wasn't
stops on this sort of world series tour
was gonna be LA the LA leg of the
tournament and it was gonna be I was
like I'm gonna play Freebird and then
like Brandon was gonna like lower like
these like wings onto my back during the
solo looked like a fog machine there's
just like ridiculous ridiculous thing
planned out for the for the show but
then they lost all their funding and
they cancelled yeah so you got to
recreate that I know right
but that's you said that was your first
youtube video that was that was the
first youtube video that was like yeah
that was actually it was before though
there was one other before that which
was aces which is Brandon and myself and
just screwing around in one of the
practice in the in the common room and
at USC and then but then the whole
DeStorm conversation where it was
clicking that you might can make a
living doing this was after that after
that yeah okay
a couple years after that in fact so so
so we go and when we come back and like
if you look at the timestamps on the
videos that we did that first week we're
doing like we're just going crazy we're
just trying everything
Twilight trailer parody Green screaming
in there boom do it Final Fantasy 13 is
coming out let's make a funny video
about that boom do a portal gun we've
been wanting to a pearl gun field for a
while what's the topic this is so you
could then make the case to join the
partner program that you were like yes
we were making the case you're putting
all the material yeah exactly this is
before you could just get in now luckily
at the time prior to that because of
Guitar Hero I had a contact it within
Google within Google YouTube because I
was I went to youtube live if you did
you yeah we were there yeah that's right
Francisco that's right YouTube live San
Francisco you remember we were there I
don't remember you were there I remember
like you probably don't remember
remember a couple people there and I
won't name the names cuz they're total
dicks to me and then they totally have
our no longer dicks to me now because of
how the tides have turned but but as
interesting because I wasn't nobody I
was like as a kid who activision brought
onto intro Jos a tree model Kanani to
play guitar I remember you yeah so I was
the dude in the little corner of the
weird set playing the first bits of Joe
Satriani putting his song through a
video game and then they threw it down
to him and we were in the crowd and we'd
remember that's right I do at was so so
I had a contact from YouTube there yeah
so then I emailed that person when I was
starting to go they hey this Parton
program thing how does that work here's
a bunch of videos and uh yeah sure go
for it approved you know so we actually
got proved in real quick compared to
some people who put a lot of time and
it's like just get disapprove the
center's there but yeah YouTube live
what a weird and I and I drove back to
the airport with some of the lxd folks
and it was like with the kid the kid the
member breakdancing kid yes he was in my
car on back to the airport I'm like sup
dude
so uh now this was really good just to
give you some perspective for people
YouTube live this was 2009 I was the
first YouTube organized event basically
ever there have been gatherings that
other people that set up but this was
insane and I remember it incredibly so
because here's by the way here's my nerd
background coming back into me I
remember it specifically because it was
the first event that the flip HD or the
flip camera was introduced at they were
trying to give him a gave everybody on
flip a YouTube themed flip they did not
give us a flip but we so we were not to
that level but we performed on the
outside stage okay yeah so we were um
yukl a girl who plays ukulele probably
Julia yeah yeah it was yeah it was a
strange thing at that time and I also
had a incredibly insightful conversation
by the one the most interest
conversation of our had with Katy
Perry's guitarist right cuz about what
Harry play because she performed right
well about what does it mean to play
guitar and be technically proficient at
guitar but play the easiest
things of all time and what was crazy is
he went into this big long sort of
philosophical like just discussion about
like you know like cuz I've trained for
this many layers and it's weird because
I'm getting famous for this but it's not
the kind of music I would like but the
same time I can't say a thing about it
I'm making such an incredible living off
of it so what and then he said he was
like well you know well this is I've
turned my sort of creative energies
towards the recording process and that
side of it because I'm not getting
creative lococo critically fulfilled
from just playing guitar you know this
is just major minor chords and Barre
chords it's like it's not difficult at
all
anybody could do this and I need to end
on this whole thing about like what does
it mean you know if what does it mean to
be a guitarist if almost anybody who has
picked up a guitar could do this job
there's almost no barrier like it's not
like you're some crazy good you know
you're not you're not freaking you know
Zakk Wylde just laying it down it's like
no you're sorry honey or Satriani right
he was really interesting to hear this
guy who's like in this sort of point in
his music career dealing with all these
issues it's like this is the most
interesting conversation I think I've
had in years
so how does that apply to where your
YouTube channel went it I don't know if
it does sell your soul for virality know
your name by the way
I will say this I wanted the early on we
met with Ray Raylan Johnson and he said
something that is I think the most
interesting thing a YouTube person has
said to me about this whole ridiculous
thing whatever this is and he said at
some point you'll have a choice and your
choice will be to give the audience your
audience what they want to see or to let
or to do what you want to do you have to
make that choice and you have to be
conscious about it and it was is really
interesting because I think about that
like every day I'm like this and and
it's it's so true because at a certain
point what you're doing builds a
momentum and inertia and a size and you
either address it and you roll into that
snowball and you give yourself to your
to the people like that or you stay away
from it and you continue doing what you
want to do whatever that is sounds
really interesting so how does that
apply to to what you and Brandon were
doing on the channel that
obviously things started to snowball
yeah yeah we started so we started you
know early on we had a lot of blog
attention because at the time and this
is something I learned and again this is
like every single thing that you do sort
of like always informs the next step
even as weird as it is so one thing I
knew from working at Fox doing video
game stuff is that video game news is
very sparse nothing comes out game blogs
are just always just hurting for
information because when the game starts
nothing to talk about until the first
screenshots come out then nothing to
talk about until the alpha-beta and then
when it comes out and that's that's
three years right so like for a game
gets announced well I want see this game
you're not gonna see anything from that
game until a year and a half from now
and you're after now you might see a
little bit that another year before you
see anything else and so it's quiet
around games all the time so there's
there's so much stuff that there isn't
that isn't out there and so early on
were like you know we weren't doing game
videos like specifically but what they
were game fiend and they had that sort
of you know they were informed by our
experiences playing games you know and
it was we would draw upon the whole
bunch of different games to do so so it
wouldn't just be counter-strike or or
Call of Duty would be all the
first-person shooters we ever played
would kind of fill into it you know so
we started getting a lot of attention
from game blocks because these guys are
hurting for content they have no
confident they come in every day like
well what can we say about all these
games well nothing's coming out well hey
here's a video that's kind of games
themes all right we can do that so early
on like that was a lot of our attention
lava or traffic was coming from outside
of YouTube you know and I remember a lot
of the conventional wisdom around
YouTube by the time was people were
saying like hey if you uh it's YouTube's
for mostly girls man all girls me I'm
70/30 female female female female
everyone say that and we're like really
because I bet you it's more like 50/50
because it's a giant site why would it
be so skewed towards women and like nah
man all the people who subscribed girls
and so I think you know we found a new
sort of we began to find a new audience
that and that has continued even though
I think to this day with the with the
prevalence of sort of PewDiePie and his
gaming channels we found a more at male
audience and we started when we were
saying people like are our demographics
are like ninety ten male female and be
like no no no no no way no way nobody
could believe it then what really and I
was thought it was funny because gang
into YouTube was I always felt like if
we went to somebody's YouTube parties or
back when people were sort of more
closely knit and had parties to throw in
the over someone's house and I was like
Brandon this feels like high school
again it feels like high school but the
difference is every single person in
this room has a number above their head
and that number is how popular they are
whether or not they're more popular than
you and that dictates how you treat them
how weird is this it was it was weird
and unsettling because I think there's a
sort of weird there was a sort of weird
attitude towards whatever this thing is
that we do or it's like holy holy can't
believe we're doing this I can't believe
I'm making money off of doing this this
could just Piron any time I better hang
on to all I can and to me that's a
remarkably short side the way of looking
at things it's like that's not that's
not I don't think it's that's okay so
you have to understand you know in a
larger context our thing that that makes
sense so so early on like we were we
were you know getting some you know blog
attention slowly and surely and I
remember specifically a Phil one of the
first big boost came from Phil DeFranco
when he posted about or you know pushed
his people towards a video that we did
called chrono trigger which is one of
the first action videos that we did you
know and it was a gunplay video effects
slo-mo and he put fuel to that and a lot
of people you know talking to them
that's where they sort of was the first
entry point and that first year was a
very sort of fruitful year we did a
shortly after that we did a vehicle
flower warfare and that was like pretty
much any girl I talked to it's the video
that they know from hearts because it
has was my favorite yes so that was our
entry point interesting yeah and it's to
me it's always interesting where people
got it got again again in on and then
that the first VidCon happened and even
at that what the time the first VidCon
happened we had a breakout panel which
was just talking about visual effects
and it was like maybe half full like a
side room half full and we were nobodies
still at that time you know I remember
and I remember specifically my where
where are we in this spectrum of things
when they were interviewing Phil on
stage of VidCon for the first one and he
mentioned our channel and it was like
it's like three people in the back like
okay all right yeah no we know where we
stand we don't understand it's
interesting though and then I get always
shifts which is always you know kind of
intersting but the focus for
this has always been at least four you
know it's it's been filmmaking you know
I went to film school I was doing movies
in high school it's just it's filmmaking
its storytellers visual storytelling
what's fascinating about YouTube is that
it's not everybody on here it has that
same focus or has that same goal you
know in the end the ecosystem supports
it just fine but that doesn't mean that
somebody on here is necessarily someone
who's trying to do narrative
storytelling you know they may be trying
to do something else and they may find
success in doing that but you know I
don't look at PewDiePie and say this is
a guy who wants to make films I see this
is a guy who understands gaming videos
and does this really well and I see
vlogging no different than the skill to
me vlogging is the modern equivalent of
the talk radio DJ who can sit in front
of a microphone and just talk for an
hour and a half and entertain you
through it like that's Howard Stern
that's you know like that ability is no
different than the ability to take a
camera and point at yourself and make a
story out of your day to day life you
know whatever that is I see a lot of
similarities in that and that it's a
single person point source broadcast
against that sort of thing and there's
these analogues to sort of older media
but here's the difference and here's
what we struggle with every day you know
so at rocketjump the coming that I have
now it's that while all these skill sets
are diverse and all these things are
different they are treated the same by
everybody by regular sort of like the
layperson it's the same thing oh we make
youtube videos that's not true though I
make YouTube views but my my stuff isn't
is different than gaming stuff it would
be like putting Howard Stern Tom Cruise
and you know the Weinstein brothers in a
room and maybe and Katy Perry maybe you
guys are just you guys are media
creators that's it it's like well
everybody is different here you know
they do different things right but
there's no delineation in terms of the
understanding of that so when they go to
people you saw you say what do you do is
I God make youtube videos in their head
that we make yeah and what you've
obviously I mean with video game high
school that you've obviously moved way
beyond what you were doing with it with
the short yea action videos which got an
audience and now you've taken that you
treated that audience into a narrative
story so isn't that the point that Ray
was talking about with you where you're
gonna do make that choice
is that the choice so I think it is I
think it is and for for myself I I can
verify this with I do not like the idea
of like oh you're such a puppet master
you knew what you're doing from the
beginning is like we had an idea we had
goals that we had set but I remember
very distinctly in Finland when I got
flown out in Finland in 2000 like 8 2009
for a Guitar Hero drunkenly calling a
friend of mine who's a producer and
being like I don't think we should do
this direct-to-dvd movie I think I need
to do something online and I think that
you need to grow an audience online
first and then make something for that
audience later but the first part is you
need an audience to do it because it's
the same idea in my hands like it's the
same thing it's like if a tree falls in
the forest and nobody's around to see
how rad it was that you chopped down
this freaking tree then nobody's gonna
know that you chopped this freaking
awesome tree down and it also doesn't
make a sound
so you need to get a bunch of people
around you for your woodworking skills
first then you can chop down trees it's
kind of like the mentality when you've
been drinking a very intense and sleepy
it goes it's a cliff it's like intensive
death all right so you gotta bring us
back to the absolute ladder fire truck
you know okay so the plane here we go
so in anyway so YouTube we got going on
that and that was that and you know
lived with salmon eco for a while then
brand I moved over to the different part
of the same building then you know we're
living in different parts of the city
now anyway it's Brandon's birthday and
we have always talked about these
hook-and-ladder trust like the guy in
the back steers right yeah yeah but like
he could just swing that back out all
the way right and the front wouldn't see
it yeah he's completed in depends not
locked in on right okay theoretically
you should be able if the guy in the
back swings the back out okay you're in
a bad situation
but then he quickly adjusts his wheels
parallel to the road and the guy in the
front quickly adjusts his wheels
parallel to the road so now all the
wheels are facing impression you can
make it look like this fire trucks
[ __ ] drifting
and it could go non-stop you drift four
lanes across the road I'm like yeah but
I don't know it's we've always talked
about uh Sam you come brand that will
always be her eyes that we're like how
would you do it well you have to
coordinate it'd be a timing thing that
guys have to turn right really hard we
have the whole thing planned out they
are wearing comms and they are wearing
comms too so we had this like just idea
for awhile and then one day the day
before Brandon's birthday we smell smoke
and like with and it's from from our
neighbor's place I'm gonna pound the
door nothing call we try and to be fair
we try everything we try called landlord
landlord tries to call their cell phone
nothing nothing it smells like smoke
fire alarms are going off in there side
of thing I'm like should we call the
fire department
probably probably yeah we should call
fire farce were there for yeah exactly
right and like both and we're like well
that's that's quick to cost/benefit if
we don't call the fire department
it could be nothing or the whole
building could burn down okay let's call
the fire department
it's a coal fire department there's a
fire department right nearby they're
like there and like a minute flat they
roll in and they but they straight up ax
that door down and it took him a while
to so we're like if anyone ever is gonna
break in it's gonna take them at least a
minute of hard axe-throwing
turns out the neighbors like left a
hard-boiled egg boiling and then the
water boil away and it caused a little
mini fire there that was it nothing real
dangerous the only egg fire real big
fire yeah everyone's everyone's had one
of those not a big deal
so these firefighters we had so from
earlier that year at e3 we stole a bunch
of nos energy drink from these nos
energy guys because they were like going
there cleaning up their booth and when
they had just cases in cases so I filled
up my my station wagon with I think 200
cases of nos so it's like like a stack
that was taller than you and and it was
just non-stop nos for a while so we were
giving them to the firefighter like yeah
oh hey how's it going you guys want some
energy and the guys like all right
awesome all right so we had this theory
come here we have the stick we start
drying it out like if you swing the back
end out and do this you could drift the
fire truck and the guy was like yeah I
guess you could they let and then as
they were leaving we're standing in the
middle of the road it's sunset it's LA
blazing red and orange this fire truck
leaving the scene
we see the back end swing out now and we
see the wheels correct and the fire
truck drifts down our road and we we
were jumping up and down in like
high-fiving it was the greatest day of
my life that is unbelievable and it was
all made even that much more vivid
because you're all hyped up on energy
drink oh yeah oh yeah every pupil
completely dilated you can't even see
straight and it's just like they did it
they drifted the fire truck well on that
note you should sign the table thank you
for joining this absolutely on ear
biscuits all right so let me see here
let's see right here well you know
here's what I'll do I will draw the
diagram that we were using to illustrate
how a drifting firetruck could
conceivably work can you give some sound
design to the drawing here boom all
right
thanks Freddy thanks very much guys
thanks for having me on and there you
have it our conversation with Freddy W
I'm gonna be thinking about that fire
truck thing for quite a bit of time I
yeah I I have thought about that I've
thought about how you could do whole
circles while going in the same
direction well I thought what he was
gonna say is that if the back starts to
turn out and doesn't stop it will get
ahead of the front right will that
happen and then you can keep going
follow momentum and make it into a
circle that's what I was thinking I
think that will happen but neither one
of us are capable of making it into a
realistic video that illustrates it he
has the power to do that but how do you
think how easy is it to come across like
an old fire truck like you can buy an
old school bus I know people who've
bought old school buses and you can buy
old police cars why can't we get hold of
an old fire truck and just own it and
drive it around you sometimes you get
the front sometimes I get the front I
think the reason is because the
investment is not justified I mean
there's I mean we could also put out
fires with it like we're a private fire
brigade that we have like a need to get
we have a ham radio we like tap into
police frequencies show up with our
hook-and-ladder
like we're here you can get really high
we could probably come up with other
things to do with a ladder that tell you
man bucket brigade
well we want to thank Freddy W for
showing up I think he's listening back
to this curious buddy
you're a beautiful man thank you for
listening we're gonna be doing this next
week in the meantime check out Freddy's
work at youtube.com slash Freddy W and
also stay safe this week stay safe stay
out of trouble stay away from fire
trucks and cuddle up next to your
significant other if you have one of
those and co-op next to some sort of
blanket or pillow if you don't have one
wait you're ending this like it like
that radio DJ like giving people some
instructions I like leaving people with
something that they can take action on
cuddle up next to someone and we'll see
it next week or you both you'll hear our
voices yet
[Music]
[Music]